hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to red dead redemption
- okay so I cut off a boss listen I'm
super sorry about that
listen I love to kiss your ass ten ways
from Sunday but if I need my sleep I
need my sleep
I need my beauty rest and he'd know
what's going on and listen boss you oh
I'm sorry Katie but stand up for two
seconds okay what was I doing I've
completely forgotten what I was doing he
was trying to talk to me about something
but then it didn't okay that's right o
our prisoner the prisoner that we just
casually have in camp and nobody seems
to be bothered by about none at all so
I'm a good babe patronage to us Oh
contribute I should probably do that
okay yeah to give money give all my
money goes into the camp because I am a
faithful son of a [ __ ] here we go I'm
proud to give what I can that's what I'm
here for that's what I'm here for baby
I'm here to the people god I didn't even
talk that right
Abigail House Marston doing is Marcin
okay Abigail just gonna look at these
chickens real quick huh there we go
Java chicken okay cool anyway I'll take
a stew ball do that eat some stew get
some provisions in me and then I'm gonna
talk that Ciaran son of a [ __ ] fine
grab a bowl stew you need to wait a few
days before being able to grab another
why I thought we were able to get one
one day oh that looks good though oh my
god oh my god
oh that just reminds yes please baby
that just reminds me I need to make pot
roast oh my god I need to antagonize
just speaking to do your own come on I
told you I don't know
[Music]
hold your horses there
it seems the cat it's got our friend
ears tongue I was thinking mr.
Williamson could have a word ready to
talk I don't know nothing okay they
ain't no friends of mine
I just written with them for a wash you
see we heard that part so how about you
tell the truth that's where you want me
to do hurt him so the next time he opens
his mouth it is to tell us what is going
on ah Mike in 103 schools boys couldn't
open his mouth but he'd tell a lie screw
it let's just have some fun
nowhere Driscoll's holed up and you're
right
he don't like you anymore you like him
he's at six point cabin I'll take you
serious I don't like him I mean I like
him even less than I like you no none
taken
why don't you take a few of us up there
right now I got this ditch all right I
mean why don't you just do that from the
beginning
so Driscoll I know Driscoll are you sure
it was yeah you ain't fooling anybody
social column needs making
okay oh you got a rattlesnake which now
now listen if you caused any trouble I'm
gonna feed you - everything's always up
past Valentine this that that this
everything's always past Valentine with
me we'll listen I've got a lot of
bullets
I ain't a no Driscoll you sure look like
I smell like horse [ __ ] that's right
Lizzie hi Morgan smoking
you got throwing knives in your
saddlebag oh I was asked to give them
and I'm doing you the further courtesy
of telling you about it next time you
want to give me something how about you
give it to me instead of hiding it
somewhere hoping the opportunity comes
up to mention it last goddamn favor ID
hey if I got my bearings it's over here
over where yeah I know this country
[Music]
right okay yeah this seems good hey Bill
[Music]
[Music]
tells you you've gone too far
what are you talking about finite big
bullet Valentine how wise you think
beating a man to death with a bat with
all them folks looking off when are we
supposed to be laying low I saw your
eyes Morgan you didn't go clever you
went soft looks at you with some big doe
eyes see that big eyes go home go free I
was fighting cold when you was
pretending to fight Indians don't call
my record into question yes your
abilities the Collier record into
question bill
isn't Bill Williamson actually like an
important historical figure maybe not
important but or maybe it's just the
name bill Williams and everyone knows
because it's bill bill bill bill Singh
bill Billy Billy bills it and for the
hills you say oh god the beautiful well
you don't know much about the O'Driscoll
but maybe I know more about you than you
know about them mongrel dogs you're out
like them you're out to survive like
them you live rock you live hard
fighting the law nature you're out for
yourself see this is what I hear no
Driscoll O'Driscoll you're out to
survive we're out to live free combs a
sneak thief and a killer Duchess that is
more like a teacher more I've been you
just look the same as all then you
looked but you ain't see John shut that
boy no
almost on
oh wait that's John oh who knows of this
son of a [ __ ] we got where this is
talking true but if it's what he says it
is and calm Oh Driscoll's here we can
use a fine here now remainder there yeah
John
it's so weird just hearing John's voice
casually this is like ten or twelve
years before the events of the first Red
Dead Redemption things off I'm guessing
the Johnny too confident about his
abilities okay okay guys guys I'm here
for you I'm all over it man except I
seem to be going off in a random
direction I'm here for you guys I'm here
with it can we please get to somebody
that we can shoot call his horse riding
nonsense okay
[Music]
all right well I'm already set ready to
go we've dismount or what let's get in
some action I want to shoot somebody
I shouldn't shot that at the top of my
lungs but here I am this feels like a
trap nerves where you put them knives
huh what are you putting where's knives
I don't see knives whatever knives
lantern knife where are the knives items
horse
I see no knives there ain't no knives
there's no knives here what a load of
palooka what a load of honk oh there
they are
alright well alright fine whatever don't
matter I like my last suit we ain't let
you loose your balls first
man you guys are obsessed with balls and
you guys concentrate on the mission for
just one seconds they you Tom Marcin I
just want to get a good look at you so
Marston get down I'm down caverns in the
clearing down there there is that be a
bunch of fellers I hang out there too
well you fellas armed aren't drunk
where are you strangers yep I'm gone no
disco
he'll be holed up in his cabin be passed
down booze blinds lightly is not over
there someone's coming
I'm gonna drain it I'll catch up no we
ain't gonna fall for that we're gonna
wait so you can tell him yourself yeah
yeah if anyone's actually gonna shoot
the messenger
it'd be that means something [ __ ] hmm
what are we doing about the pisser
Morgan won by the tree
okay here we go I got this one this
first four okay I got this one work oh
you know I've got this if I know mom men
by the back of their neck that guy's
gonna take a long time to piss probably
drink a lot
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
sorry guys listen listen listen uh 'then
nothing personal about this got you in
the knee okay listen listen this this
went wrong I listen I was just having
fun trying to shoot something over
somebody's head and it didn't work out
sad I meant to do that a little more
sneaky but it won't work
yeah I know I saw you yeah I'm gonna
make a move see what I can do about this
but it ain't gonna be good that's what
I'm talking about oh look at me John
damnit I had a bead on that guy and then
I walk paw he's on fire now
alright listen buddy listen buddy I
almost embedder off just charging in no
I'm not can't hit [ __ ] okay here we go
okay
all right there we go there we go there
we go there we go there we go that's
what I'm talking about that's what I'm
here Briana I see you
ya see him shoot him
I'm going in with the big gun you could
clear shot on them going around no know
who I'm trying to inform about my accent
over here you don't know that maybe he's
still here dude I'm ready I'm coming for
you calm down
maybe you shouldn't laugh it's a good
point Arthur that's a good point it's a
good point I won't kill you I didn't say
you were lost killing me
out there without you homo just was
gonna lose his mind about this so so I'm
one of you now
give me a break I know
come on let's get the camp so you got
the cash then well cash yes usually some
cash in the chimney I'll check it rest
do you boys get the cab quick ain't so
bad you ain't so bad
you tell DA choke tyranny worth killing
just yet right you are all right looks
like Karen's gonna be our bodies who
almost cut his balls off nothing makes
men closer than almost cut in one of the
the balls off that's for damn sure
wait hang on hello baby oh hello ha ha
double barrels of fun
alright press r3 to maintain what do I
gotta do with it cleaning weapons with
gun on would improve their condition and
performance really this does needs a
good cleaning all right I can take time
for this oh that's satisfying fetes that
is really satisfying aim it you know
checking it all kinds of check style oh
that's looking good good view of that
one oh yeah looking good looking good
looking good
how about uh how about we flip her over
oh I'm just as good on the back as it is
on the front
all right this bad boy is gonna be mine
[Music]
so although the guy on the chimney is
fist up in that chimney real quick $600
$600 $600 are you kidding me $600 just
like that just six Hyundai
you gonna give me 600
it alright um I mean I'll take it I
ain't got no problem with taking it damn
it now which I didn't drop my stuff
damage my seat there we go okay I'm
gonna get comfortable I swear it's just
so impossible to get comfortable but I'm
gonna make it okay there we go and my
legs up on the table and that makes
sense okay more money clips can I please
have all these oh my horse needs
brushing judging by what's on the bottom
left there anything in here that I can
get anything useful at all
I'll take those thank you very much
whatever that is yeah take that
give me all of this goody goody goody
goody my satchel is full Pearson okay so
I got to do that are you talking about
crime reported gold wedding-ring oh now
I feel bad about that guys come here run
from me huh oh [ __ ] oh god please don't
go
Lupul runs okay gotta eat one of these
okay I'm doing good just like I knew I
would let me get my map up let me know
where I'm going here I'm going over back
to camp okay here we go
right there okay here we go
no we're done here okay and away
[Music]
hey hey don't shoot do you think I put
this deer here oh no no no no no no no
no no no no trouble you're good you're
good swoop oh you're here good oh [ __ ]
well shouldn't I stop for that deer well
I think I might've goofin a little bit
if I had guessed something I think I
goofed it real hard
[Music]
yep
[Music]
[Music]
okay we're back on the road with no
problem whatsoever and I don't know if I
still have a bounty I do okay
that's not necessary I'm gonna skip over
that for now unless I can hit the post
office on the way through probably
should it's not like that's gonna go
away so hey Sal my fault I didn't it was
all in self-defense that we killed all
those Oh Driscoll's for some reason
built up of kind of a hate and I seem to
have lost the $600 kind of pull over the
chimney there unless that was all
supposed to be towards hot which I think
would be [ __ ] and Al excuse me
excuse me sucka use me I gotta pay my
affairs hello sir
need to pay bounty please pay and I'm
done all right okay that was a good
conversation we out there all right now
I gotta go there we go
hop on jump on horse there we go I am we
out of here all right so we're gonna get
back ya know I didn't hurt you I didn't
hurt you I did not hurt you
you hurt yourself who was a
self-inflicted accident and you know it
okay anyway wondering if I can get
Pearson to make me a better satchel not
that I'm gonna be looting a whole lot
but it would be nice to have some kind
of a backpack thinking we gonna invent a
backpack while we're out here it's kind
of round up the supplies necessary to do
that any deer in the area
now I don't see nothing
it's very rare that I'm gonna have a
chance or an opportunity to actually do
a little bit whoa sorry Peter Bonnie hey
you better book it funny you're lucky
I'm in a good mood and you're lucky I'm
really bad at hunting or else I get you
in a heartbeat who goes there it's me
John John it's me man you guys got to
wash out the defenses a little better
because I'm just barging my way and if
it's camping you are doing nothing for
it
all right hoppy off me all right guys
hey how you doing hey how you doing here
hey yeah you doing hey dude hey you in
there
what's this Big D over here was that
important I'm gonna go for the D judge
God there we go Dutch how you doing miss
O'Shea well it feels like we are finally
getting back on our feet does it you
find a buyer for them bounce me still
not yet but Jose is working on it when
we headin west soon I don't know feels
like things have changed
no world's changed cause they don't want
folk like us no more we're being hunted
we are smarter than them only the
feeblest of man take jobs in the
government Oh
trust touch mr. Morgan yeah after they
got Micah Dutch oh what's going on we
got mica Heat he's been arrested for
murder he was in strawberries okay son
breathe they nearly list me then they
got Micah in the sheriff's in strawberry
and there's talk of hanging them there's
open Arthur what the fool brought this
on himself you know my feelings about
him do think I can't see past his
bluster to the Jardin side he is a fine
no I'd saving that fool I can't go my
face will be all over West Elizabeth I
am asking he would do it for you I don't
think he would but you okay Lenny yeah
of course I'm okay you don't seem okay
you take that kid into town Valentine
not strawberry get him drunk and Arthur
no crazy business I'm giving that up and
you get mica out of that Jail how am I
gonna get him out of jail with no crazy
business literally all of my business is
crazy I'm selling at a loss I'm buying
hi I'm so low I don't know how to run a
business
I never went to business school
everything's crazy how am I supposed to
be able to do anything
well whatever let's go to the
Valentine's Day why don't we gotta get
him drunk
I've got bourbon on me kid you want to
can you ride and drink drunk drunk drink
can you drunk ride I don't know man
whatever just come on you gotta get
there yeah okay
see he's yelling again he's yelling my
crazy side off you supposed to be down
there
asking him what we was doing but he was
you worry too much kid just just some
business to attend to kid you know how
he is he was half soaked before we even
got there
then we ran into some fellas one of them
Mike a new drink some more and this is
supposed to be a dry town waiting to
marry shoot goes couldn't even tell you
quite half happened like the strike of a
match the law was on his fast too
they was ready to strangle me up there
in there but I got away just about
you're alright now
we'll take care so you're gonna go get
him I'll come with started all this ed
back okay okay what kind of fight one of
these you don't need to know the details
of that it's alright we're gonna
friendly fine the kind of fight that you
don't need to worry about until you're
getting another fight
you know what I mean excuse me you hello
ladies how you doing hey how you doing
there hey I do okay alright never mind
then see you around the bed
no okay how you doing sir hello mr. Luke
oh my god all right lean on the bar here
here yes we talk hey barkeep of course
just a drink we get a couple of beers
please you I don't want no trouble
you'll get none from me I was defending
myself ah me
thank you thank you
I could seem to know a lot of people
that was the problem now you made I mean
I don't seen a lot of crazy crazy crazy
crazy still will you shut up
but you shut up be quiet buddy oh there
dullard my lord
you managed Oh uh-huh you're sharp I
need his food alone buddy your charming
fellow one of the best but me and the
kid here oh we're trying to talk
business so could you possibly leave us
alone
no offense intended hey no pleasing some
folk
just trying to be friendly yeah okay all
right okay see you around the back hell
yeah bottoms up baby Bottoms Up bottoms
or bottoms up baby bottoms up baby
bottoms up
baby bottoms up lay Black Eyed Peas
bottoms up hello baby
bottoms up all right Lanny let it
bottoms up you know how we do bottoms up
Lenny xyx escape is made hello good
looking at you hello good bottoms up
Lenny you know how we do Bottoms Up
bottoms down
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
like out damn it lady
bottoms up oh [ __ ] hey I'm coming later
use it well hello beautiful
alright Lani laughs all right well hello
beautiful
bottoms up as they say we're Lenny Lenny
Lenny hey look
[Music]
hello beautiful how are you doing
long-legged luscious lip and me hello
beautiful wait a minute hello beautiful
any OS Tamir
[Music]
you know lucious Lenny Lenny give you a
tear
let it weigh laddie
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
my bottom lip you know how it is
BOC hello no no wait no ohh
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
bottoms up [ __ ] you gonna let it
Lenny
let bottoms up we go oh god best
sequence I've seen in a long time best
drunk sequence I've ever seen in a game
I think but that was fun no so far
there's a fine for drunken violence in
this town you're just lucky no one was
killed $10 in your freedom washer now
get out of here around here no more
yeah man they sure do make crimes easy
back in the day it's not like that today
you don't just pay your way out of jail
right this game is a goddamn delay from
start to finish this is amazing this is
amazing this
I love that I love that oh you can
replay it oh that's so fun you can just
replay it oh god that's so hilarious
goddamn just kind of rest it's gonna
rest my eyes a little bit I'm fine I'm
good
you alright okay I'm good where's my
horse let me get a little beans yeah I
gotta get my beans I can't eat beans
while I'm down all right give me some
beans nickel who needs a nickel ah who
are nickel bottom I'll buy newspaper
would he go hey you are a lot older than
I thought you were I thought you were
like a kid like that okay anyway 25
cents seems like a lot for a paper
especially this this time of day all
right come on horse we gotta go
mom's Hoople swoop we'll get over
whoopee no I don't got a heart I barely
got a horse let's go all right I'm outta
here baby
yeehaw I think I know the way back to
town at this point God that was fun
though that was legitimately great like
it's moments like that like cuz you can
do a drunk sequence in a game but that
one had so many surprises twists and
turns
like the whole Lenny sequence was so fun
just doing that over and over easily
we're letting go cuz I thought it was
gonna be one of those things where I was
like oh no we lost out on like what we
were supposed to do and oh no he's gonna
be gone forever and it's just like it's
a harmless night out or not harmless but
it's just a night out with your buds oh
wait where was strawberry that's right I
was supposed to go to strawberries mica
uh yeah let's go let's go get mica we
might as well right we might as well
yeah Mike is the son of a [ __ ] but I
guess we got to go rescue him whatever
all right I just love that like the
detail put into this game they didn't
need to put that sequence in there it's
a little bonding thing to make you feel
close to these people and I get that
they're making me feel close to these
people and then they're gonna rip them
all away from me but at the same time
goddamn that's nice
that's so cool got it it's it's [ __ ]
like that that makes games feel real
[ __ ] like that that makes games feel
like there's stakes like everything's
tangible like I would right now I would
die for Lenny I'm gonna I'll say that
right I'll die for Lenny because me and
Lenny world grows now oh we're so tight
we're good he's a good guy and now I'm
gonna get my cup and even though Mike is
a sack of [ __ ] he's part of the family
too gotta go get him that's his way it
is oh is that so
oh okay all right the a Driscoll's got
this bridge yeah where I do not have a
gun okay I'm a back off slowly I'm just
looking to pass
and I'm looking to pass also while I get
all my [ __ ] out one for you one for you
one for you one for you okay there we go
alright alright wait how many did I get
all of you you get enough you probably
shouldn't do that I mean not that it
would have helped you if you go up or
not
all right listen buddies you asked for
that plain and simple that was not me
that was a hundred percent you shoulda
let me cross I mean that's just how it
goes no self defense I'm a good man a
good man you are all bad men dad at
shootin people was 1v5 he probably
should have gotten me but no you did not
well hey I got free horse medicine hey
scoop well you didn't get shot did you I
got plenty of horse stimulant so
basically a horse testosterone horse
adrenaline horse semen all crammed into
one some horse estrogen some horse
brains thrown in there just I got a
whole horse in a bottle how am i
injected into your bloodstream so yeah
that goes for you I gotta get better
about Deadeye too because did I I seem
to be wasting a lot of uh a lot of like
possible shots because I I drag them
across their arms and the whatnot and
the like I should really aim for heads
but I can't then again with the
controller I am not that good and I
don't think I'm ever gonna do the
keyboard things because like every
goodness but then again this game is
like 40 hours long so maybe at some
point down the road I would figure that
out but right now I think I'm okay yeah
where is this god I'm never gonna get
used to how pretty this place is cuz
this place is
and like the the funkalicious thing the
[ __ ] richest thing about this is this
is just the natural beauty of America
like if you live in America you could
duck you could see all this [ __ ] I mean
it's not all civilization in America
there are huge swathes of national parks
that you can go and see all this beauty
all the nature haulers it's still there
for the time being anyway like it's
still there and it's something that can
really be enjoyed as much just as much
as like I'm an I'm a homebody and you
know I don't often get out much and I
don't I don't actually see nearly as
much as I probably should it's it's just
fascinating no why am I here okay
oh wait I'm going the wrong way yeah
this is fascinating to know that it's
still all there that like some people
still put a lot of value in those
national parks and the things that you
can see there just to see it faithfully
recreated in a game it's really nice
it's all the nuances the touches of the
people were just naked that's so special
one of these days I'm gonna go fishing
but for now I'm just gonna try to get to
mission Fisher I'm sure it'll happen
naturally they're gonna give me a
mission that's gonna teach me out of
fish I know they will but for the time
being I just take a moment enjoy it so
far and then hopefully at some point
down the road they'll show me how to
fast travel because I imagine that I
have any leg if I look at the map here I
doubt that I've even covered oh my oh my
goodness gracious what is that supposed
to be a stable okay well I guess I gotta
guess that one it's just like it's good
stuff that's all I got to say about hey
dear how you doing
I'd kill you but I guess I'm not welp I
almost ran you over so I guess I would
have gotten a free kill no matter what
all right all right good boy
oh yeah partner ain't doing hate her you
what is this this logging camp yeah
whatever oh you guys have fun I got
places to be some idiot friend of mine
is about to get hanged better get hanged
I gotta be getting close at some point
[Music]
this place is so huge myself obviously
lost I am staying in strawberry if you
could just guide me back okay think of a
good reason to say no oh thank you thank
you on the back with you
the legs work donae yes I suppose it's
just a little demeaning ah yeah you know
what else is demeaning being left in the
woods to die I'm from New York City
actually that makes sense yeah oh sure
oh yes there was some talk at the
Country Club about this burgeoning
little resort town called strawberry so
I thought it might be quite the trip to
see what all the fuss was perhaps make a
few investments while it was still
undervalued enjoying it Dan it's a town
of splinters if you could call it much
of a town at all I'd hardly skipped off
the carriage and I'd take it in the
whole place I suppose some might call it
charming these days you show me a timber
frame Jackie and I'll show you Broadway
okay
okay whatever you say man whatever you
say are you gonna keep talking the whole
way we're there are you just gonna keep
you know silent so that I can enjoy
myself we are at a trot okay credit you
must be quite the salesman he did get me
out here after all more fool me now I'm
dropping through the leaves and I'm up
with some cowboy no offence little taken
a little taken
that guy's going faster than us I might
as well just make we are not close to
town I don't even know where we are we
don't even have paved roads out here we
don't have a map and even if I did have
a map I wouldn't give it to you oh hey
there it is how did you get lost this
easily for some reason you plan to spend
any time in strawberry you may want to
look into that gabbing mayor something
is definitely off with him okay and what
you're supposed to be right you're on
you're good yeah whatever you say
I got a deal with this whole hanging
situation anyway
dumbass Micah getting himself in trouble
okay goodbye
whatever you're gonna reward me talking
into where is Micah Oh in jail obviously
excuse me alright man coming through hip
but I hope buddy who be hello boom
Barnum's up hello yeah hello sure I've
come from Blackwater I'm on the trail of
a dangerous gang como JISC heard you had
some sort of incident we don't deal with
bounty hunters around here son I was
just wondering if I could get a
description well they weren't friends
they got in a fight two men got killed
now one of them's an idiot the other is
some kind of dumb Mick so maybe them's
your boys you can look right enough when
we hang them
alright enough said thanks thank you
uh good day to you glad everyone's all
am the bull here Micah shop Micah shut
up Micah's at you down there like a god
damn it Mike Micah you yeah I'm liking
you piece of [ __ ] you gonna get me out
of here so much luster out of your mouth
these last six months do something to
you Arthur
well that's your first mistake listen
there's one little problem there's only
one of me and there's a whole town full
of people wanna see you swing you got to
do something Arthur I don't know I don't
know Mike maybe if I just slap some
dynamite onto this you might want to
step back a little bit I always read you
my English oh you really want you you
want the dynamite solution that's that's
what you want you you want the dynamite
solution cuz I've got some let me see if
I can get like my horse to uh you know
pull it out maybe if I do that oh yeah
well that didn't do nothing okay well
let's try the die
over there still works hey and I like
the dynamite route let's see about this
holy [ __ ] that is not I expect you know
some about it's just super charming
horse horse now would be a good time I
guess that's a good point
our list bang
goddamn
get out of my way Micah man I'm really
bad at this
I'm I'm I'm home buying the MoMA well
got them how are you still up I shot you
three times there you go he goes down
[Music]
oh yeah let's get the hell out here no I
don't I don't trust you at all yay oh
man maybe I should have left you in
there I didn't want to kill this whole
town god damn it Micah you piece of [ __ ]
okay well all the strawberries never
gonna recover because two maniacs
couldn't be stopped
oh you shoot and what am I gonna do all
the work for you Micah how did you even
get caught by them in the first place is
this how much damage we could do
ah
No
yeah we should we should we really
should scuse me while I loot this guy
we have killed the entire town everybody
we've killed the indent strawberries
Myka what the hell I should have let you
die nope Myka I'm gonna [ __ ] shoot you
my god
[Music]
you know how I said at the beginning of
this adventure I was like oh my cos it's
gonna be like a oh it's gonna be a fun
adventure where we get to know Mike and
maybe he's not so bad he is [ __ ]
worse and I hate him but that's also the
thing about this story is like it's
making you feel stuff for the characters
this guy's a piece of [ __ ] this guy is a
piece of [ __ ] just the worst absolute
worst possible human
- woop we'll come on good [ __ ] God
why we kill like 30 people god damn it
Here I am looting them three at this end
no okay you were all rushing me oh yeah
oh now you're now you're in a hurry now
you're in a hurry oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
of course yeah I'm in the wrong here I
don't walk into a house and just start
shooting people for guns that I could
have no no no no no I'm just an idiot
thank goodness for auto-aim anyway
whatever oh wow they get caught up in
the stores like that yeah we don't have
much choice Myka maybe it was your fault
maka
I wasn't even otto and now is all skill
baby I don't feel good about it but I
can feel good oh look at the clouds look
at the [ __ ] environment oh shoot I'm
gonna get you bang bang
all right come on we gotta go we gotta
go we gotta go gotta go gotta go
I know Pope thank you Mike and nod you
know what I'm not gonna thank you Mike I
don't even care that's much is clear
who was that skinny yeah we ran together
for a while did a bank job down south
didn't end well
I saw how god damn ended he was gonna
let me hang I'm starting to wish I had
and you old Lenny to if he hadn't found
us in time yes you will all be thanks
profusely I promise you're lucky dad
she's got your back
okay yeah I hate Micah that's very clear
all this [ __ ] but goddamn the
weather
I think that's finally lost so I'm
giving you a holster it's my way of
saying thank you only for you
to liven it up by letting me help you
sure you're a funny fellow Arthur
real funny why you act all sour oh yeah
well you ain't funny at all so why you
gotta act like the court just listen I'm
sorry but we're family now Arthur you
and me sons of Dutch makes us brothers
sometimes brothers make mistakes now I'm
heading back to my little camp run back
a strawberry come see me maybe I can
make things up to you you ain't heading
back to Dutch no I've been a bad boy
Arthur I ain't seeing Dutch till I can
bring him a peace offering yeah screw
you Micah you're a piece of garbage I
hate you and everything you stand for it
but goddamned look at the look at the
weather look at the clouds I was
marveling to the landscape I forgot that
they pulled in a huge amazing weather
system into this thing my god look at
this [ __ ] oh it's clearing up too no
comeback thunderstorm I want to see I
want to feel I'm feeling things
who is this Xavier okay that's Xavier
Reverend Swanson I haven't seen Reverend
in a while
Leopold Strauss he wants something from
me
oh let's see I'm closest to Xavier so
let's go over to see Xavier I haven't
seen him in a spell see how to get oh
god we got to go a long way around there
actually I might be close closer to
Reverend Swanson he wanted to see me a
long time ago so I'm gonna go to him he
was actually he called for my help
from the very beginning so I'm gonna go
there first good god what a piece of
[ __ ] shoots up half a town kills 30
people in cold blood
killed skinny's wife just like that a
horrible screw you Micah but I think we
can all agree that that is how that is
supposed to go down you are supposed to
hate his guts
I ain't never gonna come by ain't gonna
visit brother ain't gonna visit none of
that let's see if I can take the
shortcut of this train over the water
[Music]
I'm gonna go see hopefully no train
comes when I'm going on this maybe you
will
oh come on man let's hope we don't die
what do we want to live forever here
let's keep going come on it's all right
it's all right cool good boy I hope
there's nothing no trace no whammies
that's nothing I don't know why I
thought that was a way down I don't know
why but I did what do you need help with
who needs help
[Music]
shut up get out of here act like you
never saw this nope what the hell
come on come on shoot him good god the
shooter alright well help me man is that
it will you you're not gonna be nice
you're not gonna you're not gonna do
anything about that you know just gonna
be running away and you're not gonna
thank me I got a second bust open his
lock box then me lock breaker no what if
I aimed my weapon no no no no wait whoa
wait whoa it's okay it's okay sure I
should switch this shush shush shush
[ __ ] watch Oh Josh big show okay
this seems hardly worth it I mean this
is like some very basic levels bank
pains never mind we're good we're
even-steven everything's good in this Oh
all right good boy good boy good boy ah
come on back up through the pass
hey that's a good boy that's a big boy
all right we got some baked beans boy no
for the both of us
all right where am I going I don't know
where I'm supposed to go I'm gonna run
you down run you down dear okay goodbye
hello farm weren't you pew
aren't you a quaint little [ __ ] I wonder
if there's an equivalent of like there
was uh I forget what her name is but the
the lady who ran the farm in the
original Red Dead Redemption the one who
got in a lot of trouble like all of her
brothers died too is there with her
father like she was nice I thought that
was a cool adventure this is a lady
living with her father like being the
quote/unquote man in the house stuff
like that oh wait was that actually
where they're supposed to be I think
that oh that was where I was supposed to
be come on we got to do things we got to
help people around here hello goodbye
this here I was cute older wise here oh
well [ __ ] you stay there good bub should
named you chica took your advice then
your God has finally deserted you what
you talking about it took your advice
sir I have removed myself from Morpheus
as embrace no more so I think sir I'm
free I'm free
oh I'm free friend you seem drunk
surround Reverend wait finish you I
finished look at every spinach none of
us pours liquor down his throat friend I
just wanted to play now firstly we ain't
France
don't make no mistake on that subject
secondly he can't hardly see let alone
reason no reason and ain't never been
one of my strong points neither but see
and I do just fine you want to step
outside or do a business here I just
want him to finish the game why can't we
all just get along these are good man
after their children God
I have children of God okay well how's
about you playing his place on that
seems fair you want a game
was a big part of the first game it's
actually fine it's surprising
all right Robert rep revered by Reverend
okay sir this is Marvin okay all right
Marvin whatever you say gentlemen about
this same goes for you uh-huh ah let's
see what I got hey you two know each
other anyway I don't play poker much can
we play mom oughta slap down a good old
call on that it can't be no real
clergyman he committed about five
cardinal sins just in that chair you're
sitting in
think you used to be challenged all of
us I'll check can you imagine him at the
pulpit if you could stand out in the
Thursday water in the whiskey and
disrespect him again and you'll find
yourself in the bathtub - all right all
right
just trying to have a little fun here it
is a game after all mr. no it's not a
game don't think so well that's gonna be
your bad boom baby
yeah suck it stupid idiots all your dumb
asses give me your money I'm out of here
screw you screw off I'm okay no no no
I'm done
I'm down I'm down I'm down this is
getting too rich for me
sit down I'm done friend it's been a
real education
come on rip where's where'd it go who
the Reverend excuse me Jim
I did see him crawling there checking
under the table reverence watch what you
guys see a reverend around here you guys
see excuse me I'm sorry you see a
drunken idiot priest wandering about nor
we saw him smell Tim and avoided him
[Laughter]
yeah yeah I got an idea
all right come on swooping come on swoop
oh I'll marry you
let's go find our Reverend what the hell
whoa whoa whoa you're big man whoa
you're a bit bigger than I thought you'd
be I'm not you're going down yeah well
you
ow hey nuts all night come on what wait
what no you're not hey come on now
listen Leslie he clearly attacked me and
I okay well hey buddy buddy buddy buddy
buddy buddy buddy body body body body
body buddy you better you better let
somebody listen listen listen listen
listen listen should i body body body
you understand me all right you better
you better understand I don't know where
I'm looking Reverend Reverend what the
hell Reverend what in the goddamn hell
is wrong with you
Reverend oh god damn it okay well here
we go again with this [ __ ] horse it
come on
swoop oh come on we gotta go get the
Reverend he's being a stupid again God
look at the beauty oh my god the beauty
[Music]
Oh Reverend let's get you home home
that's a wonderful idea
I could have okay all right I don't know
who Margaret is that your wife or is
that the wife you left behind to join a
gang of criminals you know I don't I
don't actually care which I really don't
Reverend just you you get comfy on the
back of Coupole over there and then
we'll just get to good
yeah yeah Reverend it's our rule yeah
shut up Reverend a long ride ahead of us
and you need it oh god here he goes
again if you vomit on shwoop while I'm
well I'm not gonna be mad cuz I've done
the same but I'm gonna be right ticked
off this dangerous where I'm riding
right now kippers hell are you talking
about man yeah whatever
yes good boy pretty close now I can't
even stop off and get a deer if I see it
so screw you Reverend got to clean up
after your [ __ ] and whatever it's
over we're all family so cool because I
bet if I go down and see Xavier it's
gonna be another mission that kind of
introduces me to Xavier in a weird way
it's some bizarre like bonding ritual
whatever it has us doing but yeah it's
just like it's revealing the
personalities of these characters in all
of it alright alright alright okay
alright there you go Dutch Dutch we got
a delivery
Reverend Swanson here to quote unquote
help us a ditch they do yeah yeah he's
here
alright hey kid is that you little
Marston Reverend just usual poor bastard
exactly well thank you mr. Morgan I'll
keep an eye on him he was lucky this
time real lucky
yay was a little ah little marcin's gon
thought I coulda seen them hello is that
Lanny Linder bottoms up we need to worry
about okay good good good Lenny Lenny
what's going on it what's this gathering
going on over here what's happening over
here ladies so that feller who was
hassling you and Valentine I'll tell you
another time okay okay sure you need
good in town find out about that change
[Music]
okay goodbye
wait there you are oh what a tender
moment that I'm standing too close to
hello hello hello
alright thank you glad I could be of
assistance to you and everybody here
alright since I'm here I'm just gonna go
say hi to Leopold might as well right
I haven't actually talked to err Strauss
very much at all in this entire endeavor
huh
he's like the mysterious one that I
don't know anything about so might as
well find something I'll cut you in
cloning already you know how it is
people is happy to borrow of someone
like me but more enthusiastic paying
back to someone like you course let me
see a chick Mathews works at Guthrie
farm
and I believe mr. Robbo the smallholder
at painted sky runs the operations there
badly miss Lilly millet is a wrench made
up at Emerald rent here was me believing
Dutchess bluster about us helping folk
it's legal work mr. Morgan does belong
in prison we are doing them a favor I'll
make sure they oh damn good collects Bob
you gotta dance Ross just miss him some
what wait who you talkin Severn Davy
died I gotta go look at the list of
debtors okay who do we got
Lily mebut Lily millet Roble chick
Mathews you got it okay
lilies at the top let's go see where
we're lily is man that's so sad
okay ones there mr. Roble oh these are
far out okay I should probably take care
of actually I'll save that for last cuz
it's closest to the end
I'll just go here I'll hit chick Mathews
first and then we'll come back for the
other one later all right
sound good yeah it sounds good you'll be
safe here for now tell you're back on
your feet properly oh no this is the
lady we rescued thank you oh don't mind
me standing here watching the sadness
you mind if I cry oh you can stay with
us as long as you want
thank you it's nice we can do
all right well I should be getting on I
should be all right way we'll see round
okay I don't know if I could have made
that any more awkward if I tried that's
but that's how I do every interaction
I've ever had in my entire endeavor hey
horsey come here you come here we got to
get out of here I gotta save myself from
the awkward horse won't follow you if
you're in camp all right hello
nice tail Lupul all right here we go
shmoop oh sorry scoop old shoe for
trouble shmoop oh you got go collect
some dance
so let's go baby let's go we got a long
way to go
a beautiful countryside to see you know
I know for a fool what is that is that
coyotes coyotes probably sure you it's
all right whoa what is that whoa do
wield O do wield a shotgun that's so
cool
oh that's right Micha gave me a holster
which could be good or could be bad I
mean I'm not gonna thank him for that's
for damn sure what is that oh no butts
up on the ridge here okay I guess I
could just go over this way
what's going on here would you be
interested in some friendly competition
uh maybe north from Mexico to challenge
a real American gunslinger
yo him I may be a real gunslinger let's
find out let's find out that's what I
like to hear
that's why you like to hear that's what
you're gonna hear okay whoever shoots
one of these bottles wings destroy it go
on a name when you're ready all right
okay well I'm on uh oh god console that
didn't make me happy at all how about we
raise the stakes
good win drill well are you forbidding
me so compared to the win oh here it is
okay Matt oh my word okay I'll take that
appreciate it sure and a watch on next
time you'll see alright I don't trust
that I knew you were hustling me ain't
gonna be hustled mister man of word man
ain't no way you ain't gonna hustle me
good God look at this goddamn see it's
so pretty that's so pretty
[Music]
sorry I'm just losing my mind
I haven't travelled at night yet my God
always liked environments at night
there's something about it it's just so
goddamn beautiful I always loved playing
World of Warcraft at night just like
going out in the environment I mean I
mean it feel like a lot of World of
Warcraft
like back in the early vanilla days
something was very very very cool about
seeing the place is when it was empty at
night cuz you gotta think about if you
have a server in your time zone like the
people playing like they'll go to bed
but when I had nothing better to do and
I was just like living on my days
playing video games it was something
peaceful about it just questing out
there and just warming up some materials
you know how much people and how many
competitions and stuff like that I don't
know for being a for being a morning
person that I am you know there's
something there's something I really
like about night let's see Sorry Sorry
Sorry Sorry Sorry Sorry Sorry Sorry
Sorry Sorry
I mean this is something about night
that I really
I love the Stars love seeing it all love
being in the environment out there I
love like just getting the peacefulness
of it I wish I was more of a night
person I wish I was I'm just not I love
getting up the mornings cuz it's a
different time type of calm in the
morning too
you know you can see like the early
morning fog you know not many people are
up then either you feel like you're
getting a start on the day kind of like
getting ahead of everybody else and yeah
it's nice just the nice and the stars
especially bagging this time when there
was no light pollution or nothing
[Music]
yeah you do and you ain't gonna get away
with it let me just okay got my row feed
over here where you going where you
going where you going huh oh no you
think you can run hello buffalo beef
over here hey I'm uh yeah you don't want
to get me angry I don't know about that
one
that's how loans work yeah I don't know
about that one
you're about to find a face full of hurt
we'll put you down under that drain
no I do not
well that sucked for you pup got you
yeah yeah
no no no no no you're getting outside oh
[ __ ] that's not what I meant to do wait
wait whoa whoa whoa wait wait wait whoa
whoa what what hey hang on wait a minute
I didn't know but I know but I didn't
but no I didn't I was trying to hog-tie
him with that no that's no undo where
the hell am I okay base fine because the
people are here at least that's good and
this time I must stay on my horse
I'll catch this guy real good I don't
know why I'm still getting used to whole
control scheme here but uh getting
better at it so don't you worry about
nothing let me worry about something are
you worried about me
I don't think so gotcha
well beer bubble cool beer this time I'm
not gonna kick you to death in two kicks
I got some pretty deadly tips if you
know what I believe that's got to hurt
like a [ __ ] being pulled off overs like
that you're taking your teeth as well
some things happen to me my worldly
possessions are stored here why should i
why should i untie you do decent thing
how about you pay your debts when you
get them for the most part I'm owners
yeah whatever shut up alright hopefully
the next one doesn't run away and leave
me on a goddamn treasure hunt
dear well here here here it's gone well
oh that deer just got exploded out of
existence but I guess that's perfectly
normal
pretend like that didn't happen all
right how am I supposed to know which
tree Oh God okay ah is it under this
tree something I can see about this no
nothing
no don't crouch just get out of be stunt
mode all right where's this goddamn
thing I got a look at this goddamn map
it's in a hole in the tree okay so it's
in this tree it's in this draw air it is
there we got it not the best hidey hole
you've ever come up with but not the
worst I suppose man there you go all
right got that next on the list come on
Bubba
keep going Bubba who's a-coming no ki
Toki that's all right there we go
doodly-doo dead leather their leather
daddy
so heir spouse had this money to lend
out from the get-go I thought we were in
financially dire straits I didn't know
that we just had all this money to get
gone hello well not too shabby I'm
always down for a little air in the
mission give me a little skills in the
open area oh yeah but what I was saying
earlier about clink good night
like I sometimes wish I was I love the
night when I was uh when I was like
really figuring my life out one of the
things I would do and it's not like the
happiest memory that I got but one of
the things that I would do is I would
just like I would stay up all night
because I was so worried about what I
was gonna do with my life and like where
I was going then I would just go out in
my backyard or front yard and I'll just
lay down the driveway or look up at the
stars you know I think about like what I
wanted out of life what I was getting
out of life where I was coming up short
you know I didn't know how far I'd go I
had no ambitions beyond like anything in
like the normal
realm of working and whatnot but uh
something about something about this
little dream that I had who every time I
looked up at the stars I felt like there
was something more for me out there and
I didn't know I didn't know how to get
it but I knew that it wasn't just gonna
fall in my lap I knew that it was
something that needed to be like pursued
something that just like had to be
pursued cuz there's no other way that I
could do it like the only way that I
could live life is by you know actively
pursuing it but there's something just
calming about sitting there for the
moment you know not worrying about like
right now I have to go out and do X Y
Z's I wonder if I can lasso one of these
deer I can oh oh this is gonna be weird
I don't know what's gonna happen when
this happens oh no I didn't know I can
do this oh oh god oh god oh god oh oh oh
oh that's one way to do it
[Applause]
not bad boy not bad
somehow we managed that one it's easier
to hunt out in the plains here
everything is out in the open Bay waves
just like something that I recognized
very early that I was it wasn't gonna
fall into my lap like no matter what I
did I had to do it like myself I had to
make my own way and I knew that the only
way to do it was just why I like
applying my selves into a bunch of
different ways whatever the right way
was would find me eventually so how's it
going here I don't mean no trouble but
uh there's a bit of an issue hey doggie
Oh aren't you
beauty oh hello boy Oh aren't you cute
aren't you cutie aren't you cutie okay
hello sir just over there by the store
with Cooper thank you kindly wherever
that is I don't know where the store is
you have a store here howdy stranger
let's see ranch maid store a store
you'll make it next don't you take that
tone with me I thought you said you
loved me do do but what I get paid ain't
enough for one person let alone two your
money's gotta be your problem now the
only problem I got is this bleating
going on in my ear now lay off it Lily
god damn it oh hello Lily
where's our money what that loan you
took it's payday I'm sorry I don't have
it right now well then I guess we got a
big problem don't we Cooper give me what
you've got
I ain't giving him nothing except a
lessening dam - well hey
hey listen buddy listen I don't want to
do I I got manners for days it comes in
the forms of a lot of fists and you know
wingus and Angus here really like to
teach lessons I'm I'm a giver
hey y'all oh yeah oh I'm getting good at
this
yo miss me ha ha now you want to kiss me
all right oh oh never mind
is he dead he better not be dead I hope
he's not dead he's not dead is he
no no hey wait whoa whoa whoa hey wait
whoa whoa it's a debt I'm a loan shark
it's a legitimate debt geez I gotta
fight everybody here you okay I'm sure
you do okay there he goes well
Oh alrighty then
easy enough nobody's gonna mind that
that dog didn't see nothing but I've got
debts cleared and I feel bad about all
of this
they were just having some financial
woes and I just had it
what the [ __ ] hell
[Laughter]
[Music]
hey listen okay I this is not is not me
guys listen I'm a legitimate businessman
you guys need to be kind to me
getting out of here I don't know what's
oh my god this place is beautiful but
unarmed assault ain't gonna change
nothing I just got to go the way I got
to go oh wait let me get my map open and
they actually make a waypoint here okay
we're going all the way over to ol
oh we can't even make that sure okay
I believe you that I know which way
we're going here we go
through the brush and into the cinematic
camera okay so there's gonna be a long
ride that's okay
I'll be right back if anything happens
or if we get the hell man what the hell
whoa lawman wait wait wait you was just
I punch somebody Jesus
hey my dear god damn it my freakin dear
you are all dizzy now we need to get
hoarse Reviver it's okay it's okay horse
hey hey hi hi hi can you just lay off it
to get buddy all right listen I'm sorry
god damn these freakin lawmen think that
they can run the place I'm trying to
have a good time
be nice all y'all just being a bunch of
douches oh god damn it
really oh you've got to be kidding me
okay you know what you know what you're
dun-dun-dun and guess what you're done
and sorry buddy
you just got to be done now my bounces
up to 75 are you kidding me are you
yanking me are you doing give me give me
right now they're better I've been doing
enough these days I want to be done get
on with my life I'll pay my bounty when
I get the chance to can't do it right
now God bounties to collect myself and I
got a new deer that needs getting some
alas you me up one of these beauty-full
bucks and you domineer what the hell no
no I had it damn you
okay I've lost them never mind
nevermind I guess we're not doing that
cuz whatever we're just gonna keep going
flying away to where we need to be and
then we're gonna get to where we need to
go BRB Oh rainbow double rainbow so
beautiful
come on Bubba there we go let's to live
a bit down to 300 wait my bounties 300
wait why is my bounty 300 that's our
clocks
why is my bounty 300 why would my bond
to be three on just because I count a
bunch of people I didn't kill anybody
here yes I did cuz it's where strawberry
is oh [ __ ] [ __ ] dude okay yeah you know
what that's hi mr. Robbo I'm gonna need
you English speak English me so easier
I'm here for money
you borrow from German man German Nader
I'm here for money money you borrowed
from Leopold Strauss little house yeah
so it's down to pay where is it no I
have nothing very bad winter we've all
had a bad winter pal
all right you go get me the morning
[Music]
where's their money where the money
where's the money where's your money
Oh money where's your money Oh where's
the money huh where's your money
where is it okay I have anything in here
out there
and I feel bad about this
must come here with some
damn I feel I feel bad about this
[Music]
hippity-hoppity I'm so mad mm where's
the valuables what have you got hmm I'm
not a happy man
I'm not a happy man ain't happy I'm
getting real toasty in my tootsies Oh
mom grumbling up in my mumbly you gonna
give me money would you go get pain
friend you got one choice or the other
you better pick it fast oh you better
pick fast in your drawer
pop goes the weasel well that's what you
get what's in here
gold wedding-ring I'll leave that you
can have that I get it man I get it I'm
not a complete heartless bastard you
take the wedding ring well I'm coming
back for you
maybe you shouldn't borrow so much money
alright goodbye I feel like I feel like
crap about that one alright I'll be
right back as soon as I deliver to air
Strauss hello hi Lani yeah I mean I do
look like trouble so I wouldn't blame
you for being thinking that I am Nam
trouble but um alright
err Strauss I feel bad about what I've
done I've done some bad stuff eh Marston
oh there's house what am I putting in
here good morning boss good to see you
boss good to see you good to see you oh
hell yeah oh hell yeah
nice your four bucks four bucks
four bucks whoo we can get a camp
upgrade mmm fancy fancy oh hell yeah oh
hell yeah okay
[Music]
sharpen the senses medicine yeah why not
okay and do well Marston looking good
buddy looking good
last night how did you get on how Morgan
fine our counts are up to date sad sacks
a lot of them good very good my pleasure
well it's pleasure you're after there is
one other this farmer preacher fellow I
met in Valentine mr. dowlas
payin Aidid little do girl yeah another
one I certainly know the type thank you
ham Morgan there's no need to thank me
like you said it's pleasure I'm after
he's more slippery than he seems I've
tried being polite don't take any
nonsense nonsense me it doesn't have the
money beat him I know thank you and Doc
Bell all right so that's gonna do it for
this episode of Red Dead Redemption -
I'm loving every second of this game
even the seconds that are somewhat
frustrating but it's not that bad I just
want to finish it off by upgrading uh
the food a little bit and just like give
me a little bit of better food here come
on come on we gotta have a little bit
better just a little bit oh yeah Marsten
looking good
don't know why you're always body
upgrades they're not bad not bad
ooh ammunitions you know it hmm oh
that's nice oh wait is that artillery
shells why do we need artillery shell
yeah whatever okay maybe I can get a
better gun next time anyway that'll do
it so thank you everybody so much for
watching let me know what you think down
in the comments below
we are officially about what 15% of the
way through this story I mean - whoa
we're hitting about four every four
percent every time but thank you so much
for watching and as always I will see
you in the next video bye-bye